hello everyone and welcome to an early
look at monster hunter world coming to
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one early 2018
with PC to follow today we have a
special look at gameplay for you so
let's jump right in
[Music]
a monster that's been giving the
research commission a lot of headaches
has shown up again we don't know exactly
what the monster looks like only that it
sent dozens of hunters back in bad shape
so let's get right to it
open up your map this here is our
current location what we do know is that
it marks its territory with a sticky
mucus to keep trespassers out I want you
to head to this area and look for that
mucus-like substance got it
all righty partner it's monster huntin
time oh one more thing you're being
timed good luck
in monster hunter world do you take on
the role of a hunter in a lively
ecosystem a key part of hunting monsters
is tracking down your prey and to assist
with that every hunter is equipped with
scout fly the track monsters sent from
clues such as these footprints the Scout
flies are responding to the monsters
trail go get a closer look great the
Scout flies have locked on to the scent
of the monster be on the lookout for
more tracks or traces um that's not our
target we gotta stay focused on what's
important
this here is the great jack grass a
monster that can swallow its prey hole
almost doubling its size it is not our
main target however but it's
conveniently heading in the same
direction that our Scout flies have been
leading us so let's follow it and see
what it does
this should work is slinger ammo you can
use it to hit things that are far away
ah turns out it went to regurgitate some
of that meal to feed its young monster
hunter world introduces monsters that
can see and smell and hear you so
engaging and stealth is a short way of
getting the upper hand if you're clever
you can use the slinger to distract
monsters these small Jack rats are
always on high alert so a hunter is
using sound to distract them so we can
move on to continue tracking our main
target the Scout flies have picked up
the monsters trail follow the green
light they leave behind you can also
attract additional monsters materials
and environmental utilities
[Music]
we can see now the scouts line formation
is way more dense indicating we have a
pretty good grasp of the monsters trail
if you follow the Scout flies to your
target you'll locate it in no time
there that's the quest target now you've
just got to take it down you're less
likely to lose sight of a monster if you
use the focus camera the target today is
a new monster for the series called the
engineer we see that is actually asleep
right now and a hunter could wake it and
engage in combat here but the cave is a
tricky tight spot so let's try and lure
it into an open area to accomplish this
the hunter is using a new tool called
the slinger he's using the slinger to
shoot red pits which create noise and
attract a monster's attention
don't forget
[Music]
[Music]
you can use Javas to mount monsters
monster hunter world introduces new
environmental hazards allowing you to
use the landscape to trap and mount your
prey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a red pitch and scatter nuts are just
some of the ammo types available for
your swinger and each ammo type comes
with a unique set of properties
you can use jump attacks to mount
monsters
[Music]
the monster is on the move
use the Scout flies as a guide as you go
after it
[Music]
you can also learn the monster to
destroy parts of the environments but
open up new parts and in this case we
now see some fresh flies that when
struck will create a dizzying flash of
light to stun the monster
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now that the mother is enraged it
becomes more aggressive and will chase
the hunter incessantly you can actually
use this to your advantage and lure it
to another area of the map with more
environmental traps in this part of the
map we can see a rock formation hanging
on by some vines
[Music]
using the slingers versatility as the
hunter to paralyze the engineer and then
cause the rocks that fall on a monster
causing massive damage
[Music]
[Music]
every hunter is also equipped with a
grappling which can be used to quickly
gain higher ground
[Music]
and if you're mounting a monster and it
knocks you off
you can use that grappling hook to get
right back on a saddle
[Music]
body damage and scarring in your primary
indications of damage dealt on the
monster you can even set off the tale of
some species
uh-oh the great jag wrasse has appeared
once again and it looks like the engine
hath is not a fan of the competition
large monsters get very territorial at
times depending on their temperament
they were either fight or flee this time
the engine aft is to avoid the encounter
with a great Jack grass
[Music]
hunters can also Don different types of
Mantle's each with their own inherent
abilities the Challenger Mantle's seen
here is a great tool to attract the
horses attention and lower it to another
strategic location
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see the living breathing
ecosystem in monster hunter world
features its own hierarchy of predators
and prey the monster is almost done sir
chances are it'll reduce birds nests to
recuperate limping is one of the key
tales of a monster approaching its last
breath as the engine ass runs a way to
recover from the hunters onslaught the
hunter can take this opportunity to
return back to camp or formulate a new
strategy you can change your weapons and
armor here make sure you're always
prepped and ready for what comes next
for the final strike a hunter has traded
the great sword for a heavy bow gun in
monster hunter world you craft weapons
and armor from materials gathered from
your fallen prey serving a grisly
reminder of past battles whilst giving
you attributes related to that monster
here we can see the fearsome engine half
armor
since the hunter was already in combat
with the angina finding it again is very
easy thanks to the help from the Scout
fly who have already locked to its scent
[Applause]
the heavy bow gun is a high-powered
ranged weapon it does a lot of damage
and lets you use more powerful ammo
don't want to take hits like that head
on while the heavy blowgun lets you
attack in the same distance its
defensive options are much more limited
than the great sword since hiding spots
are scarce in this area our hunter will
have to use the guinea mantle to the
Silvius element will a didn't work so
well with the effect to the guinea
mantle now gone our only option is to
run and create some distance but
thankfully this maps verticality gives
us a quick way out
[Music]
utilizing the roaming giant vigor was
the hunter is able to get the health
recovery that he needs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the monsters type now's your chance to
deal some serious damage
[Music]
[Music]
the Rocksteady Mansfeld allows our
hunters in Jesus steady hand whilst
firing at a monster
[Music]
with the ability to now struggle
ferocious attacks it's time for the
hunter to analyse some payback with a
powerful wave and ammo
[Music]
and there it is quest complete and a job
well done
[Music]
Congrats now we can harvest precious
materials from the monsters and use
those to gear up for our next challenge
[Music]
monster hunter world is coming to
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one early 2018
with a PC version coming at a later date
make sure to follow the Monster Hunter
channel on YouTube Facebook Twitter and
Instagram to stay up to date with all
things Monster Hunter world also be sure
to head down to Gamescom where Monster
Hunter World will be playable for the
first time worldwide
[Music]